[Musique]
bonjour joël labbé merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous ce matin en direct sur rt
france la campagne de vaccination a donc
été lancé hier en france le chef de
l'état s'en est félicité il ya un tweet
il dit nous avons une nouvelle arme pour
lutter contre le virus
qu'en pensez vous bonjour d'abord et je
suis écologiste proche d'europe écologie
les verts mais je ne suis pas dans le
mouvement europe ecologie les verts seul
je tenais à le préciser si c'est bien
sûr beh parce que sur ce vaccin est
arrivé très vite plus vite que prévu
habituellement pour l'un pour un vaccin
maintenant c'est une chance que d'avoir
un vaccin une chance à l'échelle
nationale européenne et planétaire
voilà où moi je me suis prononcée contre
l'obligation à la vaccination par contre
favorable à l'incitation parce que il
est nécessaire de sortir de cette
situation qui est catastrophique du
point de vue culturel du point de vue
économique du point de vue du social
donc pour vous ce vaccin serait là
l'issue possible quand vous parler
d'incitation c'est à dire que
faudrait-il faire
je rappelle que quatre français sur dix
seulement sont sont d'accord pour aller
se faire vacciner
que faut-il faire moi je trouve qu'il ya
beaucoup et de plus en plus de défiance
aujourd'hui dans notre pays il faut être
prudent
maintenant il est temps ci d'aller vers
une forme de réconciliation je crois que
là il ya des critiques a donné sur la
sur la démarche qui a été prise parce
qu'on savait pas trop où on allait mais
c'était pas ou du moins le gouvernement
ne savait pas trop où ils allaient mais
c'était site est simple pour personne
et maintenant comment inciter inviter
les gens à responsabilités sans
obligation aller se faire vacciner moi
personnellement j'en ferai partie
donc vous vous allez montrer l'exemple
concrètement est-ce que l'exécutif
finalement devrait pas faire la même
chose pour rétablir cette confiance
perdue en tous cas c'est embêtant dit
répond je vais y aller quand ce sera mon
tour je veux pas être prioritaires pour
y aller
non plus mais maintenant alors après les
exemples du gouvernement tout ça moi la
question de la liberté a son importance
et libertés et responsabilités
voilà donc j'ai pas d'instruction à
donner j'ai du ressenti en disant ne
peut pas continuer comme ça le vaccin je
suppose je me méfie de certains
scientifiques apprentis sorciers mais
quand même là je suppose que l'être que
toutes les garanties ont été prises pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de d'effets pervers
majeur
40% des français vaccinés d'ici à l'été
ce que cet objectif vous paraît
réalisable vous n'êtes pas scientifique
bien sûr mais en tout cas en terme de
logistique est ce qu'on y voit clair
dans la stratégie de vaccination qui va
être mise en place
d'abord une consultation c'est son
médecin puis une deuxième pour se faire
vacciner
ça vous paraît cohérent oui mais on est
obligé d'être très prudent par rapport
aux objectifs parce qu'il ya un certain
nombre d'objectifs et de tendances qui
avaient été donnés et qui ont été
manqués alors si c'est si c'était
possible 40% pour l'été ce serait
évidemment une bonne chose pour moi
on va parler du conseil de défense qui
va se tenir demain si vous le voulez
bien un troisième le confinement est
envisagée qu'en pensez vous c'est
terrible maintenant si c'est nécessaire
eh bien il va falloir s'y s'y plier
puisque c'est tuer c'est que d'une
question de de force majeure pour en
sortir des efforts encore à faire ce qui
m'inquiète c'est c'est toute cette
partie de la population qui ne peut pas
travailler qui se retrouvent en
situation extrêmement délicate
maintenant s'il faut une nouvelle vague
de confinement pour en sortir en lien
avec la vaccination
moi je ne peux que quatre favorables
mais les maires disent aujourd'hui il
faudrait peut-être confiné de façon plus
local au niveau des régions peut être qu
et quel est votre sentiment là-dessus
oui bien évidemment
plutôt que des mesures nationales où
tout le monde est bébé est mis à la même
enseigne dans les villages dans les
communes tous ces petits commerces y
compris ses petits bistrots
qui mériterait d'être d'être ouverts
sont sans danger sans risque évidemment
il faudrait faire la part des choses et
ciblée en local d'une façon beaucoup
plus chine
joël labbé on va parler écologie si vous
le voulez bien quel bilan faites vous de
l'action des manuels macron après la
convention pour le climat le souhaitent
d'inscrire l'écologie la défense de
l'écologie en tout cas dans la
constitution
certains disent que l'écologie c'est une
opportunité politique pour emmanuel
macron pour 2022 qu'en pensez vous je
crains que oui je suis personnes
persuadées que oui parce que il ya eu
trop de mauvais signes qui ont été
détectés donné de grands discours de
grands engagements et derrière ça ne
suit pas et est au contraire on a des
signes négatifs de retour en arrière
dont ça ne peut pas tenir mais dont
celle de cette logique politique dans
laquelle ils se trouvent dans laquelle
le gouvernement se trouve ne pourra pas
fonctionner comme cela le potez soutenir
des orientations ultralibérales compte
on
il va falloir celui moins régulés pour
le pauvre la justice sociale et avancer
vers des mesures environnementales qui
sont absolument nécessaires
moi je pense qu'on est en situation de
péril et le gouvernement ne semble faire
croire encore qu'on va s'en sortir comme
cela en relançant croissance
compétitivité
ça ne tient plus il va falloir voir les
choses différemment et reconstruire un
projet de société avec véritablement le
double laugier environnementales et
sociales les les deux amants ensemble
alors vous pour 2022 ou dit vous vous
dit prêt à soutenir christiane taubira
l'ancienne garde des sceaux de françois
hollande c'est un peu là la candidate
préférée en tout cas à gauche
expliquez-nous ok je le répète on est en
situation de péril
il est temps d'en finir avec les choeurs
les querelles de chapelles les querelles
d'ego je me dis il serait important
qu'on est
la tête de notre pays d'abord non pas
une seule personne mais une véritable
équipe
mais une personne parce que c'est avec
la vème république
le vote est évidemment personnaliser une
personne qui soit au dessus de la mêlée
et je pense que christian christiane
taubira est au dessus de la mêlée
pourquoi pour quelles raisons par sa
hauteur de vie par c'est parce baisse
lorsqu'il lorsqu'elle a été ministre
j'ai pu apprécier à quel point c'est
peut-être une vraie forte personnalité
août au niveau pour moi deux chefs
d'état à même de fédérer à même de
réconcilier également je voudrais votre
réaction joël labbé sur ce fait divers
un jeune musulman fils de policier
tabassé à belfort parce qu'il a posté
des photos de lui en train de fêter noël
gérald darmanin d'ailleurs réagi je vous
propose de l'écouter et on je prends
votre réaction juste après à belfort un
jeune homme agressé parce qu'il aurait
fêté noël et ne serait pas un bon arabe
circonstance aggravante être fils de
policier
la justice a ouvert une enquête pas de
place pour le séparatisme dans notre
pays
pas de place pour le racisme d'où qu'ils
viennent est ce que ça vous a choqué oui
bien sûr bien sûr là encore on est en
situation de tension
il est nécessaire d' apaiser et apaisée
c'est véritablement derrière les valeurs
de la république
toutes formes de séparatisme et à ethan
et a laissé de côté
et quand on voit ce type de réaction
c'est absolument inqualifiable nous il
ya encore beaucoup de travail à faire
c'est c'est votre propos oui encore
beaucoup de travail à faire et est un
travail je le répète un travail de
réconciliation parce que puisqu'on parle
de 2 10 lames et de monde musulman
beaucoup de nos concitoyens musulmans
sont des gens qui veulent être athée qui
sont d'ailleurs intégré qui veulent le
rester
cela est important de travailler avec
eux et écarter tous ceux qui prônent le
véritable séparatif
on est un pays on est un état laïc c'est
important de la firme et qu'elles
pourront pas en ciblant l'islam mais
pour ta rapport à toute forme de
religion
alors que pensez vous justement de cette
charte des valeurs voulue par emmanuel
macron une charte des valeurs de l'islam
pour justement réaffirmé les fondements
de la république et le respect des
valeurs de la république
le conseil français du culte musulman en
tout cas les neuf fédérations qui le
composent n'arrivent pas à se mettre
d'accord et refuse de signer cette
charte a été publiée hier dans le jdd
est ce que finalement c'est la bonne
idée cette charte selon vous moi je
trouve qu'au départ oui c'est une bonne
idée
et là on voit encore que ce sont les
groupuscules les boules où les
mouvements les plus extrémistes qui
influence et je pense qu'il ya un moment
où il faut être ferme il s'agit du chat
donc il faut adhésion maintenant il ya
un travail complémentaire à mener pour
que véritablement 7,7 le charte puisse
voir le jour
et si elle en fait le lien entre entre
les valeurs de l'islam et les valeurs de
la république qui ne doivent pas être
possible
merci beaucoup joël labbé d'avoir
répondu ce matin à nos questions